all right Lauren
Lauren Howard where are you from
originally originally I'm from Munster
Indiana it's a Northwest Indiana like 30
minutes from Chicago yeah tell me what
your family growing up I was raised by
my grandparents
um didn't really have affiliation with
my mom much and my dad I never met he I
heard was in and out of jail so
not the best situation what was the
story with your mom why was she my mom
she got into a bicycle accident and hit
her head and she had some brain trauma
she tried to raise me but
um she just I heard was like I think she
raised me until I was like eight months
old
um but she would do some like messed up
things and from the injury yeah yeah so
she just wasn't capable of raising me
how would you describe your childhood
it was really good my grandma was super
worried about me
um there's quite the back story I was in
and out of foster care before
she was able to raise me but
um I didn't find out about that until I
was in my 20s
I was like protection I guess
um my mom put me under adoption and then
didn't tell my grandparents and then
they found out that I was in and out of
adoption facilities and they were able
to locate me and once they did I think
they were just like worried about me the
whole time but other than that it was a
good childhood yeah it was great yeah
how far are you in school
until all throughout High School yeah
yeah do you have dreams of doing
something with your life other than
um you did I knew that I wanted to
travel the world at a young age I found
traveling fascinating I was obsessed
with Egypt and places like Australia so
I just had that
um
like drive to want to uncover crazy
places
um I loved like the history of Egypt and
stuff like that so that was an obsession
at a young age but I didn't know that I
was gonna take it this far
so tell tell me what you did get into
um so I took a train from Indiana to
California it was during the polar
vortex
um I'm sure not a lot of you know what
that is but it's where the Midwest froze
over
and
so it was a crazy Journey getting to
California
um basically like The Rail lines froze
and we were stuck in Kansas City for a
couple days and I think because of that
they lost my luggage and when I got to
Los Angeles I had
like seventy dollars to my name and they
said that they lost my luggage and there
was no compensation so I literally had
this like tiny backpack and just kind of
was out there I was able to stay in this
skateboarding house I skateboarded so
that was awesome the skate Community is
like super amazing and hospitable and
they took me in and I met some girls
there and one of the girls lived in
Australia so that was like a key little
thing for me because she told me to come
visit her and I just made that a little
goal of mine
um someone told me because I was
definitely obsessed with weed at the
time this was like eight years ago and
someone told me that I should go up
North and to Humboldt specifically and
start trimming and they had like a lead
for me so I went up there I met this guy
and I had no idea but he was working
with the Asian Mafia am I allowed to say
stuff like this for sure okay
um so yeah I had no idea you're lying
anyway so yeah
so
um yeah I was working with them they
were super awesome to me like they would
get me drinks and food and give me all
the free weed and stuff like that and it
was a really good experience actually
um I got paid a couple Grand after
working a few months and the first thing
I did was got my passport for the first
time and I went straight to Australia I
booked a plane ticket for like a month
out by the time I got there I had spent
all my money this was like a little
pattern in the beginning of my travels
um spent all my money and I only had I
had specifically 69 dollars to my name I
went to Australia met up with my friend
Zoe from the skate house and I just
traveled Australia for like four months
and with the knowledge from the wheat
industry I went to this place called
nimbin it's the only place in Australia
where wheat is legalized and they have a
lot of people that are growing but they
don't really know how to grow so I took
my knowledge and I I taught them how to
harvest the plants and to trim and they
would pay me in weed and then I sold the
weed and I made it to other countries
while out there so I made weed cookies
and I made like 800 in one day which was
huge to me because I went out there with
such little money and spent it obviously
super fast but people took me up to stay
in their homes and then with the 800 I
went to New Zealand
and spent all my money there and came
back to the states and
just started trimming
um I was a super fast trimmer I would
trim like three pounds a day so I was
making like around 600 a day just
trimming and I built up my money super
fast
um my obsession was traveling so
basically with all my money I would
immediately just buy plane tickets and
spend all my money traveling and then
right before I would spend all my money
I would come back to the States and do
do it all over again so I met a lot of
people in the industry
um I would go into bars and socialize a
bunch
and I just started meeting people that
were investing a ton this was back in
2014 was the start of it for me it
probably was still illegal yeah it was
illegal so this was all black market
um as the term so and I would get
so I went from trimming weed and I found
like outlets in other ways like I would
find buyers at gas stations I'd go to
gas stations and find license plates
that said like
Alabama or you know any anywhere besides
California and I knew that those people
were only in the area and Humboldt to
buy weed because no foreign license
plate is there for anything else so I
would approach these people at the gas
station
um and just be like hey like oh you're
from Alabama how's it going like what
are you doing out here
um just kind of get them to trust me and
then I would tell them that I'm working
in the industry and they would usually
want to buy sometimes like Mass amounts
of weed
um I would get a percentage of it this
was after years of working so building
myself up as a trimmer
um I would get this percentage and
sometimes
the best buyer that I ever found he
would buy like 600 pounds every couple
weeks and I was getting
oh like a huge percentage of the cut
um
I think one time he came with like a
suit not him but his his workers came
with like suitcases and one time we were
counting out the money and it was like a
million dollars that was the most I've
ever counted in my life but it's all in
20s it took hours to count we didn't
have like a money counter we're just
counting the 20s and I got a percentage
of that and then it got to the point
where I would leave the country
and I didn't even have to work or
anything because I was just finding
buyers and getting the cut
it's suitcase is full of a million
dollars
what do we do with it what do you do
with it you go to a bank
um well my friend would invest in like
usually he would put it in houses so he
would buy houses and they kind of like
launder it uh
through usually like my friend would
have like a lawyer that he trusted and
the lawyer
was kind of like half good lawyer half
bad so he was working with
um like black market side but then also
like the White Market so he was able to
be in like the realm of buying houses
and helping launder money and stuff like
that so
um usually people that are kind of like
under
the table with all the money they have
some reputable person that like I said
it's like good cop bad cop kind of thing
but they're like stuck in the middle and
they work with us to help us buy things
like cars and houses and my route wasn't
that way I I just chose to travel the
world so I went to 31 countries
um mostly all solo I think I did I did
like five or six countries with friends
and I would always meet new people and
uh super social out there so I got to
stay with people
I would say that I the way that I
traveled
um it was all over the place like
sometimes I was super abundant and I had
thousands of dollars and sometimes I had
like I said in Australia like 70 dollars
um but it was I like that lifestyle
because it's literally like a roller
coaster and not everybody
can handle that but it just humbles me
and I mean I've met people of all sorts
and
I have so many stories it could be a
whole documentary of
things
um how many years did you do this uh
this went on for I did eight seasons in
the industry so
yeah I went on for a while
um I just got out of it officially in
February this year 2022. you can't make
the same money now that it's legal right
yeah so the pounds dropped they used to
be uh wholesale it was around like
twelve hundred dollars when I started
now pounds are going for 300 and it
takes about two hundred dollars just to
produce it so it's just
yeah not going so good for the Growers
at the moment but we're hoping it could
be like the stock market you know it
crashes and comes back
um you never know but right now
um basically what I did
there's no job for it abundantly
um
because I was transporting for years and
I would go my main hubs were Salt Lake
City New York Florida I would drive by
myself
um I would really push myself I would go
like 20 hour drives
um
for days like three days in a row 20
hours where my eyes are just like
like I'm hallucinating and I wouldn't
even drink coffee it would just
completely sober I was just on this
mission to get my 20 or 30 grand
um a lot of the people in the industry
started finding out what I was doing
because it's a small group once you're
in it and like all the millionaires
wanted
they knew that I was trustworthy so they
wanted to hire me so I had like
my phone was constantly blowing up
people asking me to do drives and I mean
it's there was so many offers for me I
couldn't keep up with it like I would be
driving to New York and my phone I had
two phones
um but one of the phones would be like
hey we have another drive for you in
Delaware we'll pay you 20 grand and it
would just be lined up but I really
didn't want to push myself because
mentally like being on the road by
myself
um it was super draining
so in the beginning
I didn't really think about it but I
thought that like oh I'm doing this all
by myself but I eventually started
hiring people and just paying them like
three grand and I would get paid 20
grand
um so I would have drivers the the
driver would have a driver for the
drivers if that makes sense
um
and I just really like hustled my way to
make as much as I could and like I said
I would spend it all on traveling I went
to
um
almost every continent except for
Antarctica
and my favorite is Africa
um
but yeah I would buy one-way tickets and
then wait for one of my bosses to tell
me to come back and do another round so
I was really addicting and I kind of got
lost in the money like going from the
girl from Indiana who only had a hundred
dollars and I don't think I ever made
more than like a thousand dollars in my
life before I went and came from Indiana
um so going from that to making like two
hundred thousand dollars in a year I
just got so lost in it like again like I
showed up to California with a backpack
and then after making all this money I
was buying all this material stuff and
doing all these runs when I say runs I
mean like transporting
um so yeah I just got super lost in it
and I was almost like begging to get out
of it because
I just was such so deep in it in the
hustle like
I'm telling you I would get paid this 20
grand and sometimes I would reinvest and
buy pounds and then go back to Indiana
flip them for like three grand each and
just make like quadruple my money
um
and then hire other drivers and make
more money on top of them and it was
amazing and abundant I'm not saying to
feel sorry for me but it just I was
drowning in it and
pretty much like the moment that I asked
the universe to
for me for it all to stop then that's
when I got busted and I was driving to
Salt Lake City my main Hub and that was
an amazing gig I had a house there
um
and
yeah so I was driving to Nevada I forgot
to mention I started out with this
little car this Camry
um and I could only fit 100 pounds in
there I say only but when you're when
people want you to transport like
hundreds and thousands of pounds that's
really small
um
so yeah I had this Camry and after doing
like maybe 15 20 runs
like multiple people wanted to so I had
one
um one person want to add like 100
pounds another person like say let me
also add to your run to Salt Lake like
another 200 pounds so I ended up having
to get a bigger car and I got a truck
and I was able to fit like four to five
hundred pounds
so that was by the time I built myself
up like maybe 30 runs later
um I was in this truck driving through
Nevada
and I got pulled over
they did not search me up first they
were just asking my story the truck
wasn't in my name because my credit and
stuff issues with that so that was kind
of a red flag and then they saw my
passport I couldn't find my license at
the time it was in my my purse and they
were like oh just give me your passport
and I did not want them to see my
passport because it it has so many
stamps on it and they would just be
questioning me so much like my passport
was completely filled at this time and I
was like no I'll just show you my
license and I was fumbling and I think
that was the point where they kind of I
got a little nervous
and they looked at my passport and they
were like you just said that you were in
California like but this says that you
were just in Egypt like a week ago
what's going on here and they were like
two months ago you were here here and
here like all these countries
so they got really suspicious and kind
of caught me up in a lie and I tried to
explain myself and get myself out of it
but at that point once they saw my
passport then they asked me to step
outside the vehicle and
um I actually got away with it but
um at first and this cop told me that
they would just drive me to a motel but
they said they needed to impound my
vehicle because it wasn't in my name and
uh
I I don't know the situation though some
law in Nevada so I was like okay that's
fine
um so I get in the cop car and they're
driving me to this Motel
and I'm about to get out and then I they
get a call the cop gets a call on the
the radio and it says that they found
illegal substances in my car because
they searched it the trunk and to bring
me back and I'm under arrest
so
yeah I
um I had I don't remember the amount of
pounds that I had but it was way over
the legal limit in Nevada it was only an
ounce at the time and I had all this wax
on me a bunch of concentrate so they
gave me a charge uh the same charges
like a crack cocaine charge
and crossing state lines and
paraphernalia so I got punned with four
felonies
on my way to jail I took it super well
actually like I just believe that
everything it's cheesy but everything
happens for a reason and I felt really
aligned because I asked to get out of it
um but on the way to the station I was
talking to the cop and just really open
about my story and obviously like a
little like lies I wasn't going to tell
them I did this 30 times but I was
saying it was my first time
um
and I just told them about my grandma
and like being raised and kind of like
an empathetic story to him and he ended
up dropping a couple of my felonies
right on the spot which was really cool
um well by the time I got to the station
they told me that
and I just uh spent four days in jail
heard a bunch of crazy stories like yeah
kills Jill's no joke it was like a 30
cell female cell and I got there and pro
tip if you ever go to jail try to get in
with like the oldest person there
um I got in with like the 80 year old
grandma and started talking to her and
they just accepted me once the grandma
did so that was pretty cool and they
were actually I told them why I was in
there because everybody there was on
like heroin and meth and they all knew
each other and in and out of there it
was a small town called Elko Nevada
um so I was like this Foreigner to them
and they were laughing at me because
they were like oh you're just like a
flower child like off a pot farm
um but yeah it was it was actually
really refreshing in there because I got
to hear some really challenging stories
and I saw a light a lot of light like I
read this book and it just helped me
through the whole process and I had a
lot of people that had my back in the
industry and they paid a lot of money to
get me out of my situation so super
grateful for that
um got out of jail how about how much
time did you spend only four days four
days yeah
and people I I tried to keep it on the
down low because you know I got to make
my call a day and I knew that I was
going to get out of there quickly but if
people found out in jail that I was
getting out I mean there's people in
there for months years
they would get like super jealous you
know and kind of
wish bad upon me so I had to keep it on
the down low but there was this one lady
that heard me on the phone and she's
like can you ask your people to bail me
out like
um but yeah overall I would say jail for
me was a good experience which sounds
crazy but it showed me a lot
um just reading that book like it was a
super spiritual book and I just
um knew that I was in the place that I
needed to be because I really wanted to
get out of it I was again drowning in it
um so I got out and I said I will never
do this again
um I just was doing the middle man thing
like finding buyers and still getting
paid
at that point
um and then this was back in 2018 so I
went through a long court process
and they took out all my felonies and I
got them expunged in the end
um because I don't have any previous
record and some of the laws changed in
Nevada throughout the process
um and after that I was on probation for
a year
I still was traveling the world
um that was amazing that's like a whole
nother story too this is just the story
of my transport traveling the world kind
of
that's probably what really opened your
mind to yeah it humbled me
um it showed me so much I actually went
vegan when I was traveling Africa
because I saw so much animal cruelty and
I love animals so much so I decided I
didn't want to eat them it's a whole
story in itself again but
um basically like
there was a lot of
animals on fire and I like whiffed it in
and in that moment I
was like I'm never gonna eat animals
again
so yeah
um you've been to all the continents
except for Antarctica yeah
and I want to continue my goal I hope to
do like
70 to 100 countries in my life when you
travel you would go for a week or a
month or oh it depends like my first
couple countries I went for five months
but when I that was when my lifestyle
was like a lot more free when I was tied
to work in the transporting gigs I would
leave anywhere for from like three weeks
to I think the longest I could be gone
was like six weeks
yeah so I was in this like they wanted
me back right away they wanted me to
drive from New York and come back and
then back and back and I did that the
first couple times
um and then I was like this is mentally
super draining and I had all this cash
on me I would I would just keep it in my
glove box I had nowhere to put it it's
stressful yeah yeah I mean I would go
crazy I would talk to myself like like
you know listen to songs
there's only so many songs and podcasts
you can listen to after hours on the
road
um one time I dyed my hair purple on the
road on the way back like I just got
bored and would do random stuff
um on the drives but it felt like a
double life because I I loved taking
photos of my journey of my world travels
and I had like a nice following on
Instagram or have whatever
um I had some a good following on
Instagram and I would get interviewed
um I got interviewed by this this huge
shoe company and I just had to lie about
like everything that I was doing and it
just felt like a double life because I
was constantly lying about my job I
didn't want people to know that I was in
the industry at all because then it
becomes obvious like the amount that I'm
traveling so I said I worked on Fruit
Farms to my family and to everybody else
or that I was an investor
things like that but I was so young at
the time like I started when I was 21.
I'm 29 now so
it's been a an amazing year of my 20 you
know a decade of 20 years 20s are
exciting yeah it was very thrilling if
you had your life to live all over again
what would you have done differently
nothing nothing at all no great
experience for you yeah
um I would have to say I'm definitely
addicted to Adrenaline
um and I have to constantly like push it
down especially on the drives people
would be like aren't you so scared to
drive hundreds of pounds and I was like
no not at all like it was not scary one
percent I was on a complete adventure
like the pounds were not in the back of
my trunk ever I would just wash it out
from my brain
um and it was just a total Adventure so
is that is that something you developed
from doing this work or you think you
had that before you started it I think I
had it where I started but I just didn't
tap into it fully
um is it related to the
the urge to travel yeah I would say so
probably tied together somehow yeah I
don't really know where it comes from
like I heard that my dad was in and out
of jail
but again I never met him so surprised
you weren't smuggling
more serious narcotics over oh I got
offered yeah okay yeah I got offered
cocaine nothing above that but I said no
to that I would I would never I would be
scared to do that
um but I got offered to leave the
country with weed and pick up cash
that's the thing a lot of the times I
would have to bring back the cash too so
in those instances I wasn't allowed to
to leave the country as I wanted to but
um that was a thrill too I mean cops
have like Radars to
track cash especially on the new hundred
dollar bills like
so they have to be all in 20s usually is
that right yeah
yeah they know with the strip the blue
strip
yeah it's all tracked
oh Dangerous Game you were playing yeah
but like I said I said I was gonna stop
and then covet hit
um I tried to
do other stuff like get a normal job but
no I just I don't know it's just not in
me like I'm definitely
um My Own Boss and will always be I
signed like this contract in my head
it's not a real contract but more of
like a spiritual contract I said I would
never work for anybody and I have not in
10 years which I'm proud of and it's
great yeah
um I have to do what makes me happy so
which is continuing to travel the world
and work on my jewelry business now how
is traveling
impacted your
view on the world on life on what you
want to do how you want to spend your
time here oh in many ways like it just
humbles you especially with money
because you see how much the world is
struggling like we are so spoiled our
problems are
not
problems at all compared to when you get
out there to third world countries like
it's a joke and it was it really really
affected me in a positive way but also
negative when I would come back and I
would see how spoiled my friends and
even I was acting in certain ways and
um I would hang out with my friends and
sometimes I would just get pissed off
because they're complaining about things
that don't even matter and it would just
affect my daily life and hanging out
with people I would just be super
annoyed at how spoiled we are
and I would be in another country like a
couple days before that coming back
seeing people on the streets like
begging for
50 cents you know and being able to use
that for a whole day to for their food
or
um just you know obviously struggling
really hard and
another thing
um with making all the money that I did
I wanted to help others and I did some
humanitarian work
and some people
obviously
are going to be judgmental about me
struggling or smuggling drugs or
whatever
um
but my soul calling is definitely to do
humanitarian work specifically in Africa
I would work with kids that were
underprivileged and there was a certain
Skateboarding company called scada Stan
it's by Tony Hawk so I went there and I
taught kids how to skateboard and just
brought like I filled my backpack up
with toys and school supplies and
after like traveling so much for leisure
and for myself going to all these
countries just for me me me me and then
I started doing humanitarian work I
realized how unfulfilling it was to
travel for leisure
so now I like to travel and do
humanitarian work work in orphanages and
stuff like that and that's where I find
it's uh
the most fulfilling for me
and then also when I would meet people
in other countries I would buy them
plane tickets
um
like I brought I brought one of my
friends with me to Egypt and Morocco and
I just love to spoil my friends that I
meet not so much anymore because I'm not
as abundant well I will be
um no you enjoy it more when you're
sharing something yeah sharing is the
best like I mean so many people I think
through social media like we put up all
these like lavish stories and posts and
stuff like that but really I just see
right through it now and I'm like this
is not
it's not fulfilling like there's no way
people can just be fulfilling for you
you
so I learned that along my way and yeah
um it's all in the balance you know
you've learned like a whole life
lifetime's worth of lessons in you're
not even 30 yet yeah
yeah people say that I've lived many
many lives more than people in their 70s
and I cherish that I feel super grateful
um when I was in Guatemala someone told
me they were like I feel so sorry for
you and I was like what like I took it
to heart I was like oh my gosh why
um but they were just saying that I was
kind of just like pulled into the system
like I was in this Loop of just
traveling and working for other people
and and that actually like really helped
me
um because I realized like yeah I was
just in this Loop and that's that's kind
of at the point where I was like I need
to get out of this because I'm drowning
in it so now my money goes so much
farther like it's crazy if you make some
people on here watching will relate if
you make fast money you're gonna spend
it just as fast and it's just this
vibration that it's just like it just
goes like I spent it so fast I don't
even know how I mean I do know how but
it's just crazy I could make the same
amount of money now and it will last 10
times longer
which is crazy and I'm not making
illegal money anymore I mean this is up
until February because I did get back
into it for a little bit
but I was only getting paid like two
grand at a time which is I say only
because before I was getting paid 20 30
grand
um
for a 20 to 23 year old
I mean how much were you making at the
peak of you're smuggling your drug
smuggling career I think the most I made
in one month was like 40 Grand
so yeah I have friends that do like only
fans and stuff like that and they're
making like a hundred grand a month and
all this crazy stuff so I definitely
like attract people that like a lot of
my friends do only fans and stuff like
that I would say
um
I just don't judge others and I think
and also like just trying to get out of
the system I just love being around
people that are like that and kind of
have the same mentality
but I don't do that because it's just I
can't it's not in my soul it's not for
everybody yeah it's not for me but I
would love to do a job where I could
just
um be out of the system any way possible
and right now for me it's just making
selling jewelry at Artesian fairs and
it's obviously not as risky but I hope
one day that I can put my story out
completely because I can like the eight
seasons on the weed farm like this is
just a recap but like there was so much
drama and crazy little things like I got
guns put to my head I got robbed in
Chicago 130 000.
um yeah people tried to take over the
farm at one point
um it also built so much like the friend
that I met he was making 30 grand a year
when we first met we were such a good
team
because he would invest money and then
send me off with pounds to other states
and uh he would we would both get a cut
from like whatever was sold that I would
transport and he just like built his way
up
um to five Farms there's a siren goodbye
[Music]
so he he built it up to five Farms yeah
so from the first year I met him uh the
second year he bought his first farm so
the land and then started growing on it
and then all the weed that was produced
on that farm I would transport to other
states and sell them for a lot more than
we could make in California and then a
mix of finding the buyers at gas
stations or uh bars stuff like that
um so I was always getting a cut which
was awesome and then he was building up
and all the money that he made he just
kept reinvesting into properties and
land
um and he ended up
like buying
like four houses or something like that
and making like 15 million dollars in
the end from like 30 Grand in a short
amount of time in like four years so or
less I think it was like three years
um and a lot of it was on the black
market scale but now he's all pretty
much White Market uh
yeah illegal
so
it's cool but also the market crashed so
right now like all of these stories are
kind of
a thing of the past which is crazy
because it happens so fast yeah you
never relive this today yeah and the
fact that I got in it like it's just
it's mind-blowing like I traveled for
six years non-stop like I'm telling you
like I went from like humble and drove
to all these places and I did not stop
like the longest I stayed in a place was
two weeks for six years
so by the time covet hit that's when I
finally got to reflect and stop and it
took me a whole year to sit back and
reflect I was like what the [ __ ] did I
just do or I don't know if I'm on it
yeah I'm like what just happened like
those six years I'm still reflecting on
things like because my memory like it
was just so fast-paced and so much that
happened
um are you a smoking pot as well yeah
yeah definitely
learn what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned from
your exciting 20s
um
I need a second to think of that one
just simple just like be humble at the
end of the day like we're all going
through stuff
and
um I know a lot of people that like Flex
what they got but it's just it's like
all fake to me I just feel like just be
humble and not non-judgmental that's the
biggest thing I learned because I've
seen I've worked with millionaires
people that have made hun like so much
money and I've counted so much money and
seen it in front of my eyes but those
people are still going through the same
thing as people that are working the
nine to five and eight dollars an hour
or whatever like they still have issues
and problems and drama and all this
stuff and are stressed out and I have
sympathy for everybody and I just after
traveling the world and seeing people in
third world countries I just try to
remain as humble as possible
um because we all have a crazy beautiful
story and
um you know
we don't know people's mental health and
what they're going through so I love to
spread love and give long hugs and all
that stuff just to
trying to make the world a little bit of
a better place because it's crazy out
there and one person can change
so yeah beautiful Lauren thank you so
much for sharing your story thank you
good luck with whatever you do from here
yeah I appreciate it I definitely want
to write a book
um or like I said have my stories
um I just want it on a mass level but I
want to like really tell like from the
day-to-day stories and like each country
I went through and give little tips on
solo traveling and I really want to
either write a book or have it
um I mean it would be cool to have like
a documentary you have to document it
somehow it would be great yeah
all right well good luck thank you so
much thank you